[موسيقى]
نحن هنا
الاثار والعيون والزيتون هناكب رحله الذهب
الاخضر زيت الزيتون
[موسيقى]
ولا تؤذي حبه
بيتنا وجديدنا الكنافه
وهو كل شيء عنك
وزيتون وانواع والكل
شيء معنا
تتمسى الزيتونه الزيتون
[موسيقى]
ياكل منه بره بحر بتعرف شنو بره بحر
معناها البر الي نحن فيه والبحر اللي فيه
البحر
[موسيقى]
لا يشبهها خطا رغم تطور التكنولوجيا يسر
القائمون عليها على التطبيق الاسلوب
القديم وهو سر الاقبال على منتجها
تقوم بعمليه استخراج زيت الزيتون
زيت زيتونه برزق لا يذكر غرسه كبقيه زيت
العالم لكنه تصدر مرارا المحافل الدوليه
كواحد من اجود انواع الزيوت على الاطلاق
نبارك اللون ولاده الطعم تغفر له ما
يتكبده اصحابه قبل ان يستمتعوا بالذهب
الاخضر الى صباح العربيه احلى من عبد
النور تونس